Hi everybody! Nikki here with an all-new Nikki's Wiki.
Today, we'll be talking about fairies!
My favorite is Tinker Bell from Peter Pan.
Did you know that different cultures have all different types of fairies?
Some are sweet and helpful,...
...while others are tricky and mischievous.
Some have wings, some don't.
Some are as small as mice,...
...and some are as tall as you and me!
Some people don't think fairies are real.
Those are the same boring people who don't believe in Santa...
...and who don't think Peter Pan can fly.
I feel bad for those people.
Okay, one of my favorite types of fairies comes from Ireland.
Yep, a leprechaun is a type of fairy!
Just like Lucky with his lucky charms!
I love my lucky charms!
In Ireland, leprechauns like to hide from humans and play tricks on us!
But you can keep them on your good side...
...by leaving out bread and milk for them to eat and drink,...
...as many Irish people do!